it did take us all by surprise didn't it
but are we know the point that we can
identify exactly where carbon mania has
come from who's supporting well we're
not really at that stage yet what we
have is one poll we've we've conducted
one poll of Labor members and that gives
us a snapshot of where they stand at
that time and there's still a lot of
time to go we know that Corbin is more
supported by women the men we know that
his support tends to be from people
who've joined the Labour Party more
recently compared to older members and
we know that he's more popular with
trade unions but in no case is it
overwhelmingly so and there's still a
lot of time to go if there's one thing
we know from all the leadership election
polls that we've run both the
Conservatives and for labor it's at a
lot can happen and I expect that some
strategic voting that our polling showed
up that's around 1 in 4 1 in 5 people
who's voting at the moment for burner
more Cooper and then putting put in
Corbin as their second preference that
may evaporate but the point is we don't
know because we don't have the data as
it stands and James turning to you
you're a a devotee of Jeremy Corbyn you
that the Labour club at Oxford
University where you're at the first to
dedicate it to clear its support for
them what is it about a ticket that so
many people see as a return to some
clearly dark days for the Labour Party
in the 80s that appeals to someone like
you and well for me politics isn't about
personalities it's about issues and on
the issues that a lot of young people
care about Jeremy's the only candidate
who's offering a clear and principal
policy so whether that's free education
or living wage rent control scrapping
Trident and Jeremy actually isn't a hard
left Canada as he's been caricatured as
and these mainstream most people support
those policies and at least according to
what people in YouGov's say and for
young people well young people have been
hit much harder by austerity if you're
young you're three timeslots being
employed you more let's have your
benefits sanction and you're more likely
to be exploited in the private rented
sector and some of us might now be
graduating with over 50,000 pounds of
debt and so young people taking a
battering over the last five years and
in this leadership election it's only
been Jeremy Corbyn who's proposed
policies that have made
a clear break from the Tories I just
want to bring it bring in a be here as
well as one of those that well according
to you at least should have been
transferring her affections from that
obviously the middle of days of Millie
fandom over to jeremy corbyn but you
haven't instead you've gone for andy
burnham I'm hoping that that's not the
kiss of death for him what's you saw
what's the rationale what is the
reasoning and what it is it about Jeremy
Corbyn that got you presumably disagree
with James about just how attractive his
policies are two young people and well
I'm starving I entirely disagree James
about that I just think that Jeremy
Corbyn would find it harder to lead a
United Labour Party and I think lik to
be strongly ever have to be united when
people need us to be strong so I think
Anna needs the best connect UNITA
partying this we'd have a stronger
Labour Party under antivenom nollywood
Joan common George uh statistic taking
us back to the numbers is it possible no
on your understanding of where Jeremy
Corbyn is at the moment what happens
when you take out those at first
preferences is it possible that within a
few months we are going to see Jeremy
Corbyn as leader of the Labour Party it
is possible but it's by no means
guaranteed when you run through the
numbers when you run through the first
of the second preferences and see how
things divide is really too close to
call and that was back when we were
pulled a few weeks ago and so there's
plenty of time for things to her things
to change when you ask the general
public what they think of these are
these candidates around a third of
people so they don't know they don't
know about any of them and so there's
this is all a some hypothetical
discussion and there's definitely more
to come I'm afraid we're going to have
to leave it there at your time in the
studio Abby Tomlinson and James Elliott
thanks very much for joining us sorry
it's so brief